- It is no cliche
that consultants create
lots of PowerPoint slides.
During my time in consulting at McKinsey,
I probably created several thousand pages
over the course of six
years that I was there.
But the more experience
you get as a consultant,
the more you notice that a lot of people
outside of consulting,
even those who are working
for large multinational corporations,
many of them are really not good
at creating these PowerPoints
slide presentations
to meet the level and the expectations
of senior leaderships of large companies.
So we come to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and on
my channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And today we are going indeed to talk
about slide presentations.
By the way, if you wanna know more
about creating slide presentations
in the style of consulting firms,
I have a full online course
only dedicated to the topic.
I will link it below in
the video description,
so check it out if you want to
learn more about this topic.
So let's get going.
The insight that I want
to share with you today
is the importance of avoiding clothelines.
And already briefly touched
on this in another video,
but this concept is so important
that I really wanted to go
a bit more in depth on it.
So stick in here with me.
I will, of course, add lots
of new thoughts of this
in this video.
So what is a clotheline?
As a young consultant who
does his or her first slides,
this would be a feedback point
that you very, very often get,
that you really cannot do slides
that contain a clotheline,
but indeed, outside of consulting,
you see slides like that all the time.
And indeed clotheslines are
probably slides like this.
A clotheline is a list of bullet points,
an unstructured list of bullet points.
Something like this where you
have thought one, thought two,
thought three, four, five, and so on.
So you talk about a
topic, you create a slide,
you write bullet point after bullet point.
That is a clotheline.
But why is this bad?
Where the problem with this is
that this more or less seems to be
like a result of your brainstorming.
So you're talking about a specific topic
and you're just writing
down all your thoughts,
bullet point for bullet point.
But are these not all relevant thoughts?
Are these all the most important thoughts?
Are there maybe more thoughts than that?
Maybe there are, maybe there aren't,
but for the reader of this,
for the recipient of this communication,
it's very difficult to get the confidence
that the things that you
have here on the slide
are indeed all the relevant thoughts.
This would be my very
first recommendation.
So what you should do is,
you should always come from a structure,
say, when you talk about these topics,
there are these two or three main topics
that you need to consider,
and then in these main topics,
then there are these thoughts.
So my first recommendation here would be
that whenever you have a list of bullets
that you wanna bring
forward for a communication,
you should group them,
you should cluster them into groups.
And then also include
these groups on the slide
to also communicate the structure.
Because as soon as you do that,
you can say something like,
so I looked at this topic and
identified three main areas,
three main groups, three
main clusters to look at,
one, two, three.
And then within these clusters,
then there are the thoughts
that you wanted to talk
about in the beginning.
Now, in terms of going
even one step further,
what I would recommend you
to do in these situations,
even to format it a little bit more,
often something like
separator lines like this
can help to clean it up a little bit more.
But then also let's include a title,
because without that, it
often looks a bit random.
Okay, so there are these
groups, they are these thoughts,
but what exactly are these thoughts about?
What exactly is this, that
now you are sharing here?
So often a simple title like that
can help to create clarity
of your expressions
of your thoughts that you want to share.
Let's just make an
example that for instance,
you're talk about measures, levers
that you propose for your business,
for instance, to save costs
or to grow the business,
or to anything else.
And now let's title it also this way.
Let's title this, for
instance, key measures,
because if you do that, it
also helps your thinking,
it helps your writing that
indeed not every single point
should be such a key measure,
and shouldn't be just
like a random thought
that you had that you wanted to add here.
Now what I would argue is,
that if it were this way,
it's still not a perfect slide.
It's still a very text-heavy slide.
Now you did introduce some groups,
but it still seems a little bit dull.
And now if you would really
fill all of this with text,
the slide will likely be very text-heavy
and then maybe, indeed still
not really making it easy
to comprehend the key messages
that you wanna bring forward here.
So what I would recommend
you always to do,
if you do text-heavy slides like that,
but think of different categories,
think in different types of messages
that you wanna come
across and communicate.
And often for instance, when
you talk about measures,
there will also be other
things that you can talk about.
Maybe for instance, you
would want to introduce
some examples for these measures.
So some very tangible
suggestions of what could happen,
or maybe you have a title of a measure.
and then another information
where you explain this title,
explain what this is about.
And here this is always
a great opportunity
now to divide the slide
into different columns.
That you don't only have
one key text column,
but at least the second one.
Here on this example, first of all,
a description of the measure,
but then also always an example.
So this often enriches
the slide, adds details,
again, helps you to provide a structure
and helps it to be more easily digested
because now the person knows
what the measures all about,
and then also an example
how to make this more digestible.
So hope you can really see the difference
from going from this,
so just an unstructured list of thoughts,
to such a structured
version with a header,
and to maybe even integrating
different types of information
to enriching the slide in this direction.
I can only tell you
that this is a technique
that is extremely frequently used
in consulting when I was at McKinsey
and I trust at all the other
consulting firms as well.
So I can only encourage
you to use it next time
you work on such a slide.
Now I know that I do have many people
who are also very
experienced in slide writing
in the audience,
so let me know, please,
in the comments, below
in the comment section,
do you agree with that?
Do you have any other tips to share?
I'd love to hear from you.
Of course, as always,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
I would very much appreciate
if you could hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
turn on the notifications
and subscribe to the channel.
My name is Heinrich,
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
I now want to say also big thanks
to all the members of the channel.
Thanks for supporting this work here
that I do on Firm Learning,
very much appreciate it.
And if you want to continue
your learning journey
with Firm Learning, especially
also on slide writing,
I will link here in the end cards,
a video where you can continue that
with additional content
that I have on this topic.
See you again next weekend. Bye bye.